michel fize leur 29e manifestation des
soignants qui refusant notamment les
conclusions du ségur de la santé pour
eux ce n'est tout simplement pas
suffisant ok j'ai envie de dire on prend
les mêmes et on recommence
les conflits et en paraissent de l'ue
sont toujours sur la table
on le voit avec cette conjonction
inédite aujourd'hui des gilets jaunes
pour lesquels il n'y a pas non plus les
solutions qui était attendu et on le
voit avec les ans à l'ailé le personnel
soignant pardon pour lequel évidemment
les accords d'hier sont très très loin
de résoudre le sinistre de l'hôpital
actuel on a l'impression qu'il ya un
problème de communication l'en je pense
que là cette fois on est définitivement
dans un grand malentendu on a
véritablement l'impression que d'un côté
le pouvoir
regarde les cordons de la bourse voit ce
qu'il peut peut-être ce qu'il a envie de
débourser
et puis de l'autre côté il y a
évidemment tous ces français qui
regardent eux leurs besoins et qui
exprime la revendication d'un mieux
vivre et encore une fois pour certains
d'un vivre tout simplement dignement
dans une société démocratique
vous parlez de la convergence des luttes
on l'a vu aujourd'hui les soignants et
les gilets jaunes on a également vu dans
la rue des infirmiers des médecins des
policiers des enseignants est ce que
dans un avenir proche
on va vraiment arriver avec à cette
convergence des luttes avec tout le
monde en même temps dans la rue vous
savez il ya un proverbe qui dit à force
de tourner autour du pot
on finit par l'atteindre je crois qu'on
est un peu dans ce cas de figure la
france ressemble ou stromboli un cheval
ce volcan toujours actif et qui est
quelquefois ensommeillés qui paraît
profondément endormi et qu'une étincelle
suffit à réveiller et bien voilà nous
sommes sur un volcan sociale
sur un archipel de difficultés qui n'ont
pas été résolues et que les grands
discours
les exercices de communication qui
paraissent à des années lumières de ce
monde là ne réussiront pas en d'idées
alors s'il vous écoute bien pour la
rentrée en tout cas ça n'augure rien de
bon
savez on avait tant de fois annoncée la
mort des gilets jaunes pour constater
aujourd'hui qui sont toujours présents
je crois que les français restent des
citoyens globalement en colère qui sont
soucieux d'avancer véritable de
conditions de vie qui permettent encore
une fois d'exister dignement dans cette
dans cette société donc l'endormissement
n'est pas la mort donc tout laisse à
penser qu'effectivement à la rentrée des
congés et sur fond peut-être d'ailleurs
d'un retour de crise sanitaire
ce qui n'arrangerait rien parce que la
crise sanitaire s'ajouteraient la crise
économique la crise sociale et pourquoi
pas la crise scolaire puisqu'on on voit
mal des conditions normales de
rétablissement du retour à l'école
michel fize merci d'avoir est en direct
avec nous sur rt france rappelle que
vous êtes sociologue